Michael Lewis's latest book flash boys
sets its sights on the world of
high-frequency trading that complex
arcane practice only performed by the
most sophisticated investors armed with
the most powerful computers except
actually it isn't all that complex at
all it was a major plot point of
Superman 3 remember Superman 3 it's the
crappy one with Richard Pryor in it
Pryor's character engages in a little
fiduciary malfeasance commonly known as
salami slicing here's how it works
an employee's paycheck is always rounded
down to the nearest percent which of
course raises the question where do all
those functional scents go what priors
character does is take all of those
little fractional cents leftover from
each transaction and deposit them into
his own secret account in each case the
individual theft is very small but in
the aggregate it Nets him a ton of cash
Oh
now in many ways this is a lot like what
high frequency traders do they buy
stocks just before other people do and
then resell them at a small increase
pocketing the tiny profit like priors
paycheck Scheme each transaction is so
microscopic that no individual would
ever notice or care what was going on
but over thousands or millions of trades
it really begins to add up all you need
is a very high-speed data connection and
a computer just like Richard Pryor